hello and welcome to see you again FMS
m3m what does he have that you borrow
opening know the very soft attack 3
against this holy just 96 oh wow wow
that looks weird combining a 93 with
Bishop g5 no game I just develop stuff
just look like before is weakened a bit
and really wonder the bishop here what
the bishop only five is doing that it
does not want to take on f6 at cm
really add up Knight f3 yeah 94 looks
looks like normal so let's do it and not
think too much there and give him any
time advantage
take one c3 take 125 okay I'll take them
maybe 90 x g5 isn't all that bad now for
me not too bad I didn't didn't really
exploit this now why it is okay now yeah
not sure what what what I did too long
down yeah I don't want him to play click
f5 my development is really worked on
him let the risky move but i was
thinking night to form has no
development it could be an extremely
sick decision well it looks extremely
tempting so let's see what he does Queen
85 and this combined the tech down on c
3 h 0 and so on looks very interesting
let's see what he does and well you know
what you can do we can just check on b5
I'm such an idiot
because Queen d7 he will just take and
take f7 right sometimes I really wonder
just developing is a good decision and I
just not doing it
wow wow
so even a question if you can just kill
me immediately yeah this is probably
unnecessary but it might win yeah why
does it wind I don't see it this is this
was him I don't see why it wins maybe it
doesn't he could have just taken b7 be a
lot better and so did I was attacked I
can check and take them night you can
take be seven and d5 is still hanging
there is a distillation really that is
hanging okay come on the time is really
bad so let's let's just speed up we are
giving up some stuff for the sake of
champion okay no tricks
let's see I have Queen g5 and takes f 5
which would win some campaign in some
cases as also the caption c3 yeah so
this text c7c 3 not not working yet also
not working okay let's develop stuff how
threatening book takes you three which
was ignored
yeah I can do that and the ship here no
I can take can I do something I where I
do something better there check here
maybe know why it might work okay I
think I'm taking this and just play this
he has a couple of pawns but he cannot
easily use them I think hope believe it
what's him Jack Jack getting this ray
Scutter he's got what is that he's got
through you right now it's quite a lot
but I'm getting a pass on my cell phone
on the Kings side they're not moving
that quickly yeah b6 I have to sacrifice
it back in his face got a sick so I
forgot about that that was a stupid ass
stupid thing I shoot hello totally hate
to lose this game but i will i will
really oh my god yeah check check check
track 45 photo caption Moragne I'm such
a Mon getting out of this after playing
this crap you know ok and then check I
got a winning position in scoring again
probably I'm holding it was winning I
don't believe in this ok 92 was winning
completely and this is not winning it's
a bit of shame really yeah okay i think
i should i should win here I don't
believe this after after I got them h2
well the engine doesn't believe the film
itself this is equal yeah maybe he's
quick enough with the pause and 92 and
so on I mean okay I played the opening
so badly I probably deserved to lose but
you can also questioned this which is
completely unnecessary
so it was a yeah you made it it's it's
this chest you know but it was really
really terrible game they're both sides
yeah and and this isn't exactly
difficult to see yeah you know we cannot
do that check is this check and this is
just playing the Queen so nice bit of a
hold of this game okay thanks for
watching